hi everybody
how's it going I am so excited to be
here um see old friends new friends I've
met today and future friends on the
beach
I almost got well I did get emotional on
the CSS comp stage I promise I'm not
gonna like cry or anything like that
because I'm I actually have something
really serious to talk about and that's
sorting all day yesterday people would
come up to me and they're like what are
you gonna talk about it is comfy it's
like literally in the schedule and I
don't I don't lie on schedules I don't
lie ever but I'm so sorting sorting is
something that I love to talk about I
love sorting algorithms it's something I
studied a lot and so I'm really happy to
be here at my first days comm talk
talking to you about this dynamic and
exciting subject and it's something that
I've been doing my entire life even
before I became a programmer because
yeah I'm a programmer I'm going that out
there I used to sort my my Lego
collection by colors and form factor oh
the irony I collected trolls and I
sorted them by like hair color and
outfits and stuff like that money we all
sort money this is my real money we sort
our family members by how much money
they give us during our eighth grade
graduation that's not my real family and
arrays get it arrays
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
so arrays are something that we most
commonly use how many people here have
never dealt with an array in their
JavaScript programming so arrays
everyone goes to Anton and ask him about
Jay s hints later on after the show so
arrays are the most popular data
structure in computer science and you
might be thinking that like most things
that I say I've made it up on the fly
but it's true and I did a lot of
research after lunch today
and if you see on brainy quote which is
a site with quotes on it you search
array there are quite a few quotes that
are literally about arrays there's two
whole pages of them and two might seem
like a small number but if you search
another data structure on fond of linked
lists there are no results for that so
like nobody cares about linked lists and
even stranger than that since linked
lists are pretty prominent is that like
on this page M&M is considered a popular
author which i think is a pretty funny
but you're not here to write here to
talk about M&M you're not here to see
M&M you're here to see me so my name is
Jennifer and I am finally okay to admit
that I am a JavaScript developer wait
list off my shoulders um I am an open
web engineer at boku I work with Adam
and a bunch of other cool people that
are here today and we do a lot of open
source development work in the community
consulting and education and education
is really important to me and I really
do enjoy bringing new topics and getting
more people into development and so I'm
gonna talk to you about sorting and
what's the harm in it and that's the
title of my talk and talk about how we
can sanitize inputs for more optimized
JavaScript so sorting what is sorting
you know it's when you arrange objects
of some sort you know into a or
depending on whether you wanted
ascending or descending or by some
certain taxonomy and last month I spoke
at Empire jeaious and I gave you know a
not as serious talk is this about the
computational complexities of sorting
algorithms implemented in JavaScript and
I think it went really well I had a lot
of people come up to me or like oh you
know I'm studying computer science like
you did and and I really you know like
to see algorithms implemented in
JavaScript it's more applicable than dry
you know pseudocode but then I felt bad
because I realized that sorting it's
kind of messed up so what we're going to
do is talk about not sorting arrays
sorry I I opened up LinkedIn today by
accident and wait this is Dara Singh
okay there we go so arrays what are
arrays it's a systematic arrangement of
objects here's an example of an array of
integers 7:10 and 1 and we have this
nifty sort function that we can call on
it which will actually not sort the
array well it does support the array it
sorts it lexicographically the first
column int n is 1 and that comes before
7 so technically it does that but still
like that's kind of ridiculous and you
can according to the atmosphere you can
you have to give a compare function and
you can basically tell the computer how
to sort the array and when you give that
that compare function it does it which
is like that's fine but like that's a
lot of work for me and then if you take
this example who here like sports anyway
so sports ball so like I was born in New
York I followed New York sports um and
so the Knicks and nets are two
basketball teams I've heard and if you
take this array of strings and you call
the sort function on it like yeah it
does return that same ray cuz already
sorted lots of new graphical II but
like on what planet would the Knicks
come before the Nets honestly they're
like five behind the nets in the ranking
so if I like decides to change sort to
sort by a best team I get an error that
sort of a best team is not a function
which is like messed up so this is
something I discovered after I talked at
the last conference and that sorting is
is broken which is not surprising
because it's a social construct and most
social constructs are broken so for one
it doesn't sort right we have to do all
of the work we have to tell the computer
how to do things and like what's the
point of computers if you have to tell
them how I don't know also they're way
too many algorithms to choose from
there's just so many of them and there's
always new ones coming it reminds me of
like one time I went to this tea salon
in my town I live in Montclair New
Jersey I'm going to Jersey City soon and
there's a tea salon there as well and
when you walk in there's like five
hundred types of tea and you go to the
counter and it's completely overwhelming
and the lady the carrier will say like
what kind tea do you want and I go like
oh like the best tea I guess and then
they laugh at you cause like how are
they supposed to know what the best tea
is for you and that's the same problem
that we have with sorting algorithms
there's just so many of them fortunately
this is the only part in web development
where we have that paradox of choice and
that's with sorting algorithms but uh
and then like if you think that all
these listed here are the same sorting
algorithm they just have different names
for some reason but they're all the same
so we also have to deal with the paradox
of choice of names for a single sorting
algorithm that's actually based off a
bubble sort which if you know what
bubble sort is you probably should never
be using it
unless you're teaching people why they
should never be using it so we have
people who are developing algorithms
because they don't understand the other
ones and they're not sure which ones
they want and now we just keep doing
more and more algorithms and it's kind
of a nightmare so I'm thinking like we
need to like stop sorting completely
um because sorting if you don't sort
then you don't have to deal with like a
lack of efficiency when you're using
sorting algorithms I have nested
for-loops you're you know you're dealing
with quadratic orders and that's like
tons and tons of operations and there
are some sorting algorithms where if you
want to sort a phonebook with it
it will literally last hundreds of
lifetimes nobody will see it sorted so
we can get rid of that by just not
sorting it and also if we put the work
on our users and require them to sort
for us we are making them smarter and I
feel like we're not really giving our
users the benefit of the doubt I've
never had I've never seen or heard of
any issue where a user was not able to
use a certain technology so I think we
should sort of give them that um so I
looked at a bunch of these I guess these
only JavaScript projects that and I
wanted to see if other libraries and
frameworks and tool sets and whatever
you guys want to call your thing so you
can't compete against the other ones
that are already out I wanted to see how
they were handling this problem with
sorting and if any of them were giving
some sort of method or you know to allow
people to not have to sort and they
didn't so I had created jorts sort which
is a framework for sorting ambitious web
applications
thank you have a good rest of your
conference so yep I don't get black hole
Sun this time so I'm just releasing this
exclusively here at JSC um for all of
you I've never shown to anybody I kind
of got worried because my friend Stanley
Twitter user a but sandal made this joke
and then my dad tweeted about it and I
was like don't blow up my spot dad so
George sort solves the three hardest
problems in computer science one sorting
sucks I've already proven that web apps
are slow I think a lot of the talks
about performance at both CSS content
AHS comp have shown that things get slow
and also users aren't smart as us and um
but like you're probably thinking like
Jen you just said that there's like a
million like algorithms but jorts or
isn't a sorting algorithm it's a sorting
tool set so let's take this complicated
application as an example I have an
array called my array what's those same
three numbers which you'll probably
encounter a lot in your apps we have a
function that we want to call and all it
does is it says this will alert sorted
items and then it will go through each
item and print it out and then we call
our functions
there's no sorting in this so it's super
efficient but like let's say and I'm
gonna do some live code in here look at
all that was fast
so first it's a little small but it'll
say this will alert sorted items and
then it's was one ten and seven that's
not sorted like why didn't it sort well
we didn't have the sorting function
inside of it I was kind of hoping that
my array would already come to me sorted
and that's the problem it's embarrassing
but like so if
uh mr. DeMarco earlier gave a really
interesting talk on algorithms as well
and and I figured I'd throw some
pseudocode and to impress you as well so
would I look basically the concept of
jour is if the array is sorted then
awesome if not yell at the user because
it's their responsibility to give a
sorted array and so here it is in
JavaScript so you just listen if else
statement and you call George sort my
array and if it is sorted then awesome
if not then you just throw a jour error
at them so using an app will finally be
a two-way street it'll be really dynamic
the users can interact by providing
their own input that is sorted which is
really awesome and it's actually not a
new concept because - in two ways we're
web 2.0 came from so this is like
next-level stuff happening also your app
will only work if the input is sorted so
you don't have to worry about that
embarrassment from my early example no
sorting no problem so you're probably
wondering what's under the hood of
George Soros
this is short-sword ladies and gentlemen
joints art is a function it takes an
array it sorts the array it compares it
to the original one if they are the same
it says true if they're not the same it
returns false
it's literally JavaScript it's not magic
it's abstraction
what is abstraction being a master's in
computer science to know that so lot of
people out there are gonna be like Oh
Jen like technically you're still
sorting and I'm a hater and one day I'm
gonna chocolate ice cream on my dad
weren't Neapolitan examples of a look I
wrote short sort so you didn't have to
so honestly you should be thanking me
right now so you might be thinking like
this has got to be a joke and you're all
laughing but and let me put some music
the satire have a professionally made
logo I don't think so
sorting algorithms don't have logos the
satire of a professionally made website
that's a real site let me take let me
show you jor taught technology we have
the logo up on top and this site has the
three things that you need to look for
in a website parallax
Tech shadow and smooth scrolling to show
off the parallax and as a bonus I
embedded a gist so you can copy and
paste the code so let's talk performance
cuz that's really like the issue at hand
here it can be on one line minified and
you're probably thinking like Oh any
code to be minified on one line but like
my library minified is 30 lines it's
super lame short sword is 4 kilobytes
embers like more than 4 kilobytes so
like you probably want to you're
probably saying like let's see the j/s
perf gen so here I have a snippet of
code with sorting and just to show you
that sorting is less efficient than not
sorting with that same array we call
sort and we alert the array and then
this is the code without sorting one
less line of code
could you imagine sorting 5 million
things that's like five million lines of
code that you've just saved yourselves
so here's a JSP 86% slower when you have
code with sorting than you do without
sorting 86% guess who was born 12 years
before 1986 this guy
so we need to spend more time sorting
out our lives than we do our arrays need
to spend more time Jordan so you're
probably thinking like wow this is
really groundbreaking stuff it's it's
all alive for you to use today Gorge
technology but what does that mean for
the future of sorting what are we gonna
do with all these algorithms can you
throw algorithms in the garbage can you
set them on fire do we have to go back
to our past code or we're sorting and it
you actively fix it all I don't know you
can do whatever you want my main concern
is what is the future of jorts sort and
that's testing this I've been tested
this at all so that is jorts sort you
can see it all on georgia tech nology
and you're welcome that is it